This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. For the past few weeks, we've been looking at how race, religion, and identity intersect with the criminal justice system. Previous episodes have looked at the effectiveness of the broken windows policing strategy, the effects of implicit bias on shootings of unarmed black men by police officers, and how music, specifically rap music, shapes the way judges and jurors think about crime. Today, we shift our attention to terrorism. In a speech in early February, President Donald Trump talked about the dangers of what he
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦兰塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。在过去的几周里，我们一直在探讨种族、宗教和身份认同如何与刑事司法系统交织在一起。之前的几集探讨了“破窗”警务策略的有效性，隐性偏见对警察枪杀未武装黑人男性的影响，以及音乐——特别是说唱音乐——如何塑造法官和陪审团对犯罪的看法。今天，我们将注意力转向恐怖主义。唐纳德·特朗普总统在2月上旬的一场演讲中，谈到了他所谓的
called radical Islamic terrorism. Radical Islamic terrorists are determined to strike our homeland as they did on 9-11 as they did from Boston to Orlando to San Bernardino. He criticized the media for not adequately reporting on the threat. It's gotten to a point where it's not even being reported and in many cases the very very dishonest press doesn't want to report it. Is the president correctest press doesn't want to report it. Is the president correct? Is the media failing to report accurately on terrorism? Is political correctness keeping us from grasping the true danger we face?
所谓的激进伊斯兰恐怖主义的危险。激进的伊斯兰恐怖分子决心袭击我们的国土，就像他们在9·11事件中做的那样，就像他们从波士顿到奥兰多再到圣贝纳迪诺所做的那样。他批评媒体没有充分报道这一威胁。情况已经到了甚至无人报道的地步，在许多情况下，非常非常不诚实的媒体根本不想报道它。总统说得对吗？媒体对恐怖主义的报道是否不够准确？政治正确是否阻碍了我们认清所面临的真实危险？
Political correctness kills and causes it will cause death. You can't fight something effectively that you can't talk about. This week we step away from the politicians and the pundits to look at the empirical evidence, social science research into how the American media actually cover terrorist attacks. We will also look at what effect that has on our perceptions of terrorism and our attitudes toward the Muslim community. New research has found that there are indeed systematic biases in coverage, but not in the way President Trump suggests. A perpetrator who is not Muslim would have to
政治正确会杀人，并且已经并将导致死亡。你无法有效对抗一个你甚至不能谈论的事物。本周，我们暂且抛开政治人物和专家，来看看实证证据，即关于美国媒体实际上是如何报道恐怖袭击的社会科学研究。我们还将探讨这会对我们对恐怖主义的看法以及我们对穆斯林社区的态度产生什么影响。一项新的研究发现，媒体的报道确实存在系统性偏见，但并不是特朗普总统所暗示的那样。一个非穆斯林的肇事者必须
kill on average about seven more people to receive the same amount of coverage as a perpetrator media cover terrorism and what effect this has on us this week on Hidden Brain. In 2014, two terrorist attacks occurred six months apart. They had eerie similarities. In both cases, two police officers were shot and killed. In both cases, a third victim was shot as well. Both ended with the perpetrators killing themselves. In the aftermath of the attacks, investigators learned of criminal records, misstread flags, and anti-government threats on social media. The first incident occurred in June 2014 in Las Vegas. It was carried out by a husband and wife team.
平均多杀死大约七人，才能获得与一个……媒体如何报道恐怖主义以及这对我们有什么影响，本周在Hidden Brain。2014年，发生了两起相隔六个月的恐怖袭击。它们有着惊人的相似之处。在这两起案件中，都有两名警察被枪杀。在这两起案件中，第三名受害者也被枪击。两起事件都以肇事者自杀告终。袭击发生后，调查人员发现了犯罪记录、被忽视的危险信号以及社交媒体上的反政府威胁。第一起事件发生于2014年6月的拉斯维加斯。它是由一对夫妻档实施的。
We learned this afternoon the identities of a Las Vegas couple who ambushed and killed two police officers and gunned down a civilian who tried to stop them. The couple was Jared and Amanda Miller. Investigators described Jared and Amanda Miller as anti-government and on a mission to kill police officers. On the day of the shooting, Jared posted this on Facebook. The dawn of a new day may all our coming sacrifices be worth it. The Miller's then covered the bodies with a swastika and a gatson flag, first used in the American Revolution, emblazoned with the words, don't tread on me."
我们今天下午得知了拉斯维加斯一对夫妻的身份，他们伏击并杀害了两名警察，并枪杀了一名试图阻止他们的平民。这对夫妻是贾里德·米勒（Jared Miller）和阿曼达·米勒（Amanda Miller）。调查人员将贾里德和阿曼达·米勒描述为反政府人士，肩负着杀死警察的使命。在枪击发生当天，贾里德在Facebook上发布了这样一句话：新的一天已经来临，愿我们即将到来的牺牲都是值得的。随后，米勒夫妇用一个卐字标志和一面加兹登旗（Gadsden flag，最初在美国独立战争中使用，上面印有“别踩我”字样）覆盖了尸体。
They left a note on the bodies of the slain officers. It read, this is the beginning of a revolution. The couple then walked to a nearby Walmart and ordered customers out. When they were challenged by one person, they killed him too. The rampage ended when the couple were confronted by authorities, Amanda shot and killed her husband and then killed herself. That was the first attack. The second one that we'll examine today occurred later the same year in late December. Before dawn on the morning of December 20th, Ishmael Brinsley led himself into his ex-girlfriend's apartment in a Baltimore
他们在被害警察的尸体上留下一张纸条。上面写着：“这是一场革命的开始。”随后，这对夫妻步行到附近的一家沃尔玛并命令顾客离开。当遭到其中一人的质问时，他们也将其杀害。这场疯狂的暴行在夫妻俩与当局对峙时结束，阿曼达开枪打死了她的丈夫，随后自杀身亡。那是第一起袭击。我们今天将要检查的第二起袭击发生在同年晚些时候的12月下旬。12月20日清晨，伊斯梅尔·布林斯利（Ishmael Brinsley）闯入了巴尔的摩一个郊区的前女友公寓。
suburb. He pointed a gun at his own head and threatened to kill himself. When she talked him out of it, he shot her instead. She was injured but survived. Ishmael then got on a bus to New York where he shot and killed two police officers in Brooklyn. In a note he posted to social media earlier, he said he was intent on carrying out retribution for police killings of unarmed black men. Police say one of the last posts he put on social media was this. I always wanted to be known for doing something right. He said, my past is stalking me and my present is haunting me. The post followed with another ominous warning. I'm putting wings on pigs today, he wrote.
他用枪指着自己的头，威胁要自杀。当她劝服他放弃时，他反而开枪打伤了她。她受伤但幸存了下来。随后，伊斯梅尔坐上了去纽约的巴士，在那里他在布鲁克林枪杀了两名警察。他在早些时候发布到社交媒体上的一纸条中表示，他决心为警察枪杀未武装黑人男性的行为进行报复。警方称，他在社交媒体上发布的最后几条信息之一是：“我一直想因做对了一件事而闻名。”他说：“我的过去在纠缠着我，我的现在在困扰着我。”这篇帖子后面跟着另一个不祥的警告。“我今天要给猪装上翅膀，”他写道。
They take one of ours. Let's take two of theirs. On balance, these two incidents are fairly similar and that they've both killed two police officers. So we should expect more coverage because of the targets because of the fatalities. This is Erin Karnes. She's a criminologist at Georgia State University. This is Erin Karnes. She's a criminologist at Georgia State University. Erin and her colleagues have been studying the way that the media cover terrorist attacks and the amount of coverage different incidents receive. The Miller is actually killed in additional persons. You'd expect that if anything that might have a little bit more coverage. But that isn't what Erin and her co-authors found. Ishmael Brincely received about four and a half times more coverage than the millers, and he was Muslim.
他们带走我们一个，我们就带走他们两个。总的来说，这两起事件相当相似，因为它们都杀害了两名警察。因此，由于袭击目标的性质和造成的死亡人数，我们本应预料到会有更多的报道。这是埃琳·卡恩斯（Erin Karnes）。她是佐治亚州立大学的一名犯罪学家。这是埃琳·卡恩斯。她是佐治亚州立大学的一名犯罪学家。埃琳和她的同事们一直在研究媒体报道恐怖袭击的方式，以及不同事件所获得的报道量。米勒夫妇实际上还多杀害了一人。你会期望，如果有的话，这可能会获得稍多一点的报道。但埃琳和她的合著者们发现的情况并非如此。伊斯梅尔·布林斯利受到的报道大约是米勒夫妇的四倍半，而且他是穆斯林。
The fact that Ishmael Brincely's case received so much more coverage than Jared and Amanda Miller's could be explained by a number of factors. Perhaps it had something to do with the fact that his attack was in New York City, while the millers were in Las Vegas. New York is a bigger city, the center of the news media. Concerns about Mayor Bill de Blasio's relationship with the New York Police Department may have added fuel to the fire. The story came at a time when race and policing was often in the news. But Aaron Carnes and her fellow researchers have
伊斯梅尔·布林斯利案受到的报道比贾里德和阿曼达·米勒案多得多，这一事实可以用多种因素来解释。也许这与他的袭击发生在纽约市，而米勒夫妇在拉斯维加斯有关。纽约是一座更大的城市，是新闻媒体的中心。对市长比尔·德布拉西奥（Bill de Blasio）与纽约警察局关系的担忧可能为火上浇油。这个故事出现时，种族和警务问题经常成为新闻头条。但埃琳·卡恩斯和她的研究同行们发现
found there is another factor that determines which attacks catch the attention of the media and which don't. of found, there is another factor that determines which attacks catch the attention of the media and which don't. When the perpetrator is Muslim, you can expect that attack to receive about 4 and a half times more media coverage than if the perpetrator was not Muslim. Put another way. A perpetrator who is not Muslim would have to kill on average about 7 more people to receive the same amount of coverage as a perpetrator who's Muslim.
研究发现，还有另一个因素决定了哪些袭击会引起媒体的关注，而哪些不会。当肇事者是穆斯林时，你可以预料该袭击获得的媒体报道大约是没有穆斯林肇事者时的4倍半。换句话说。一个非穆斯林肇事者平均必须多杀死大约7个人，才能获得与穆斯林肇事者相同数量的报道。
Perhaps this is not a huge surprise to you. If you've watched coverage of a recent terrorist attack, you might have a sense that this was the case. The results themselves, I don't think, were very surprising to myself and to my colleagues. The magnitude of the findings, though, is something that we were all taking a little bit of back by, that it's such a drastic difference in coverage when the perpetrator is Muslim. Aaron and her colleagues did not include broadcast journalism in their data set. In other words, this analysis does not encompass the dramatic coverage on cable news. Coverage like this.
也许这对你来说并不是一个巨大的惊奇。如果你看过最近对恐怖袭击的报道，你可能会有一种感觉，事实确实如此。我认为，研究结果本身对我以及我的同事来说并不是非常惊人。不过，研究结果的惊人之处在于其量级，这是我们所有人都始料未及的——当肇事者是穆斯林时，报道的差异竟然如此之大。埃琳和她的同事在数据集并未包含广播新闻。换句话说，这项分析不包括有线电视新闻上的戏剧性报道。像这样的报道。
US officials believe Farouk's wife, Tashfin Malik, had been radicalized before stepping foot in the US, raising alarm bells about the fiance visa she came in on. And I thought that was when we've been reporting law enforcement officials identifying their suspect as 29-year-old Omar Sadeiki Matin, as we've said, a US citizen.
美国官员认为法鲁克的妻子塔什芬·马利克在踏入美国之前就已经激进化，这引发了对她持有的未婚夫签证的警惕。我以为那是当我们报道执法官员将嫌疑人确定为29岁的奥马尔·萨代基·马廷（Omar Sadeiki Mateen）时，正如我们所说，他是一名美国公民。
But we should also point out that the New York Daily News has been on a g-Hod against conservatives over the last couple of weeks. The researchers look mostly at print news sources, like the New York Times, the Washington Post, the Wall Street Journal, local papers from around the country, as well as CNN.com. Ironically, it's these mainstream media outlets that are routinely accused of political correctness in their coverage of terrorism. The researchers studied these sources for their coverage of terrorist incidents within the United States.
但我们也应该指出，《纽约每日新闻》在过去几周里一直对保守派采取攻击态度。研究人员主要研究了印刷新闻来源，如《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》、《华尔街日报》、来自全国各地的地方报纸以及CNN.com。具有讽刺意味的是，正是这些主流媒体在报道恐怖主义时经常被指责为政治正确。研究人员研究了这些来源对美国境内恐怖主义事件的报道。
They looked at a five-year period from 2011 to 2015. This study did not look at foreign news sources coverage of terrorism or how the US media outlets covered terrorism in other countries. To identify cases to study, the researchers use the data set called the global terrorism database. The way that terrorism is defined within the global terrorism database is talking about the threat or use of violence, the incident having a political, religious, social, or economic motive, being committed by a non-combatant and with the goal being, you know, for fear, to coerce or intimidate a population.
他们研究了从2011年到2015年的五年期。这项研究没有考察外国新闻来源对恐怖主义的报道，也没有考察美国媒体在其他国家如何报道恐怖主义。为了确定要研究的案件，研究人员使用了名为全球恐怖主义数据库（Global Terrorism Database）的数据集。全球恐怖主义数据库中对恐怖主义的定义是：谈论暴力威胁或使用暴力，事件具有政治、宗教、社会或经济动机，由非战斗人员实施，其目标是，你知道的，为了制造恐惧、胁迫或恐吓民众。
Jared and Amanda Miller were self-identified white supremacists. They were affiliated with a far-right group. They intentionally sought out and killed police officers and said it was the beginning of a revolution. This would fall cleanly under the global terrorism databases definition of terrorism. But Aaron and her co-authors have noticed that the media, and in turn the public, do not apply the terrorism label evenly. That was the case with another attack that same year. After the Frazier Glen Miller attack in Kansas back in 2014, where Frazier Glen Miller,
贾里德和阿曼达·米勒是公开身份的白人至上主义者。他们隶属于一个极右翼组织。他们蓄意搜寻并杀害警察，并称这是一场革命的开始。这完全属于全球恐怖主义数据库对恐怖主义的定义范畴。但埃琳和她的合著者们注意到，媒体以及随后的公众并未平等地应用“恐怖主义”这一标签。同年发生的另一起袭击也是如此。在2014年堪萨斯州弗雷泽·格伦·米勒（Frazier Glen Miller）袭击事件之后，当时弗雷泽·格伦·米勒，
who was a former leader of the Ku Klux Klan, killed three people at a synagogue, yelled Hyl Hitler at the end of the attack, this wasn't described as terrorism very commonly in the media, which led one of my co-authors, Dr. Anthony Lemieux, to write a piece then about why we aren't applying this label to this particular attack even though it clearly fits within it. To examine how people draw conclusions about which cases of terrorism should be labeled terrorism, the researchers conducted a study. We have presented participants with real-life terrorist attacks, and what we found is that
他是三K党的前领导人，在一家犹太教堂杀害了三人，并在袭击结束时大喊“希特勒万岁”。这在媒体中通常不被描述为恐怖主义，这导致我的合著者之一安东尼·莱米厄（Anthony Lemieux）博士随后写了一篇文章，探讨为什么我们没有将这个标签贴在特定的袭击上，尽管它显然符合该定义。为了检验人们是如何就哪些恐怖主义案件应该被贴上恐怖主义标签得出结论的，研究人员进行了一项研究。我们向参与者展示了现实生活中的恐怖袭击，我们发现的是
when the perpetrator of those attacks was Muslim, people were much more likely to consider it to be terrorism than when the perpetrator was not Muslim. In those cases, people were more likely to say that perhaps it's a hate crime or not be sure how to classify it. The problem with studying actual incidents of terrorism is that each one has many idiosyncratic features. It's difficult to tell whether differences in perception and coverage in cases such
当这些袭击的肇事者是穆斯林时，人们更有可能认为这是恐怖主义，而当肇事者不是穆斯林时则不然。在这些案件中，人们更倾向于说这可能是一起仇恨犯罪，或者不确定该如何对其进行分类。研究实际恐怖主义事件的问题在于，每起事件都有许多独特的特征。很难判断诸如贾里德和阿曼达·米勒枪击案与伊斯梅尔·布林斯利枪击案等案件在看法和报道上的差异，
as the Jared and Amanda Miller shooting and the Ishmael-Brincely shooting, are because of the identity of the perpetrator or some other factor. To address this problem, the researchers conducted an experiment. They control for all sorts of different factors. Volunteers were given descriptions of fake terrorist attacks, including the location, the number of casualties, and other details. Holding everything constant, volunteers saw the cases differently when the perpetrator was Muslim.
究竟是因为肇事者的身份还是其他某种因素。为了解决这个问题，研究人员进行了一项实验。他们控制了各种不同的因素。志愿者们得到了虚构恐怖袭击的描述，包括地点、伤亡人数和其他细节。在保持一切不变的情况下，当肇事者是穆斯林时，志愿者对案件的看法有所不同。
What we found here again is that even if the target's the same, the weapon is the same, if the perpetrator is Muslim, the participants are much more likely to consider that to be terrorism. The tendency not to consider that to be terrorism. The tendency not to give some cases of terrorism that label, and to cover other cases more intensively, shapes the way we all think about the phenomenon. Erin and her colleagues looked at how many terrorist attacks in the United States
我们在这里再次发现，即使目标相同，武器相同，如果肇事者是穆斯林，参与者也更有可能认为这是恐怖主义。不倾向于将某些恐怖主义案件贴上该标签的倾向，以及更密集地报道其他案件的倾向，塑造了我们所有人对这一现象的看法。埃琳和她的同事研究了美国究竟发生了多少起恐怖袭击
are actually carried out by Muslim extremists. The result might surprise you. So if we look at these attacks in this five-year window, we see that only about 12% of them were perpetrated by Muslims, whereas over 50% actually were perpetrated by some far-right cause. But most people don't perceive that as being what the actual threat is. To be clear, that 12% number is disproportionate. Muslims account for just 1% of the US population. But in a rational world, this should mean that 12% of the media's coverage of terrorism
实际上是由穆斯林极端分子实施的。结果可能会让你感到意外。因此，如果我们看一下这五年窗口期内的这些袭击，我们会发现其中只有大约12%是由穆斯林发起的，而超过50%实际上是由某种极右翼动机发起的。但大多数人并不认为这就是实际的威胁所在。需要明确的是，12%这个数字是不成比例的。穆斯林仅占美国人口的1%左右。但在一个理性的世界里，这意味着媒体对恐怖主义的报道中应该有12%
would be of terrorism committed by Muslims. When we come back, we'll hear about some of the psychological reasons this doesn't happen. Stay with us. My name is Munibah Salim, and I am an assistant professor at the Department of Communication Studies at University of Michigan. Munibah Salim studies how the media cover terrorism. She is also interested in how the media can change the way we relate to one another. Her interest in these subjects goes back to her own childhood. Munibah, whose Muslim, was in high school in Ohio when the September 11th attacks occurred.
将是关于穆斯林犯下的恐怖主义。当我们回来时，我们将听到一些为什么不会发生这种情况的心理学原因。请不要离开我们。我叫穆尼巴·萨利姆（Muniba Salim），我是密歇根大学传播学系的助理教授。穆尼巴·萨利姆研究媒体如何报道恐怖主义。她还对媒体如何改变我们彼此相处的方式感兴趣。她对这些主题的兴趣可以追溯到她自己的童年。身为穆斯林的穆尼巴，在9·11袭击发生时正就读于俄亥俄州的高中。
As even a high school student had to answer questions regarding, you know, why did this individual think that this was a right thing to do? Or what does my faith say about these kinds of actions? And to be honest, at that point, I'm not sure if I even knew what to say or how to answer these kinds of questions, but I did have to answer them nonetheless. As a teenager, she struggled to understand the shift in the way others thought of her. The fact that I was a Muslim was enough
作为一个高中生，甚至不得不回答关于“这个个人为什么认为这是一件正确的事情要做？”或者“我的信仰对这种行为有什么看法？”之类的问题。老实说，在那个时候，我不确定自己是否甚至知道该说些什么，或者如何回答这些类型的问题，但我无论如何都不得不回答它们。作为一个青少年，她努力去理解别人对她的看法所发生的变化。事实上，我是一个穆斯林，这就足够了
to put me in the same category as these perpetrators who had committed these terrible crimes. And it didn't matter that I was a teenager or that I was an American or that I was Pakistani. It just what mattered was that Muslim identity, that seemed to kind of over-encompass all of the other information that people had about me. And so I was asked questions regarding, you know, what is Islam, what does it say about these acts of terrorism? And do you believe in the kinds of things that these people did?
把我归入与这些犯下可怕罪行的肇事者相同的类别。无论我是一个青少年，还是我是一个美国人，或者我是一个巴基斯坦人，这都不重要。重要的只有那个穆斯林的身份，它似乎笼罩并压倒了人们关于我的所有其他信息。因此，我被问及诸如“什么是伊斯兰教，它对这些恐怖主义行为有什么看法？你是否相信这些人所做的那类事情？”之类的问题。
Do you sympathize with what they have done? Do you hate Americans? Are you anti-American? I mean, all of these series of questions that I had honestly never faced before. Munima remembers one instant several years later when she was watching a play. And there was a joke about American politics.
“你同情他们所做的事吗？你恨美国人吗？你反美吗？”我的意思是，所有这一系列的问题，老实说我以前从未面对过。穆尼巴记得几年后的一天，当时她正在看一场戏剧。剧院里有一个关于美国政治的笑话。
The entire audience laughed in the theater, and I laughed as well as in my friends, and this couple that was sitting next to me. But then I noticed that they were very aware of the fact that I was laughing, and during the intermission they made this comment where the lady turned around and she said, you know, it wouldn't hurt you to be more supportive of America. And I thought about why was I being pointed out for laughing as opposed to everybody else in the audience who also thought that was a funny comment. As a social psychologist today, Munibah Selim understands many things she did not understand
剧院里的全体观众都笑了，我和我的朋友以及坐在我旁边的一对夫妇也笑了。但随后我注意到，他们非常清楚我在笑这件事，在中场休息时他们发表了这样一番评论，那位女士转过身来对我说：“你知道，支持美国对你来说也没什么坏处。”我想知道为什么只有我因为笑而被指责，而观众席上的其他人也认为那是一个好笑的评论，却没有人说他们。作为当今的一名社会心理学家，穆尼巴·萨利姆理解了许多她当时并不理解的事。
as a 15 yearold kid in Ohio. Terrorism doesn't just have physical consequences, it has a number of psychological effects. For one thing, simply reminding people of death, as September 11th certainly did, can change the way people think. It did a lot of things, it increased this concept or mortality, which psychology shows that whenever that happens, we also then tend to have more ingrouped cohesion, which basically means that we tend to kind of stick to our in-grues, we tend to be more patriotic, we tend to support things that are of our nation a little bit more.
作为一个在俄亥俄州的15岁孩子。恐怖主义不仅会产生身体上的后果，它还会产生一系列的心理效应。首先，仅仅是提醒人们想起死亡——9·11事件无疑就是这样做的——就能改变人们的思维方式。它做了很多事情，它增强了死亡的概念，心理学表明，每当这种情况发生时，我们往往也会有更多的小群体凝聚力，这基本上意味着我们往往倾向于坚持我们的小群体，我们往往会更具爱国主义色彩，我们往往会更多地支持对我们的国家有利的事情。
So it provided a lot of those kinds of psychological effects as well. Munipa also came to understand why many Muslims were seen with suspicion in post-911 America. It has to do with something called salience. When you look out of the world, certain details seem to pop out at you. They are more salient than others. We generally like to think about ourselves and the groups to which we belong in a more positive manner because it makes us feel good about ourselves. So any group that we are not a part of, that's what's referred to as our out groups, and so
所以它也提供了许多那种心理效应。穆尼巴也开始理解为什么许多穆斯林在9·11之后的美国会受到怀疑。这与一种叫做“显眼度”（salience）的东西有关。当你放眼世界时，某些细节似乎会跃入你的眼帘。它们比其他细节更引人注目。我们通常倾向于以更积极的方式思考我们自己以及我们所属的群体，因为这让我们对自己感觉良好。因此，任何我们不属于的群体，这就是所谓的我们的外群体（out-groups），所以
that information is always going to be examined a little bit more closely and scrutinized a little bit more closely and scrutinized a little bit more closely. So what that means is as a woman, for me, the behavior of other women's perhaps, especially when it's negative, is not going to be as salient as a behavior of another man. So one of those key elements is the fact that for a lot of our American audience who are non-Muslim, that Muslim identity was salient. The second part, of course, is that the perpetrators had claimed that they were doing this
这些信息总是会被稍微仔细地检验一点，并被稍微仔细地审视一点，并被稍微仔细地审视一点。因此，这意味着作为一个女性，对我和其他女性的行为来说，尤其是当它是负面的时候，可能不会像另一个男人的行为那样引人注目。因此，其中一个关键因素是，对于我们许多非穆斯林的美国观众来说，那个穆斯林的身份是显眼的。第二部分，当然是肇事者曾声称他们这样做
in the name of Islam. And so that identity or that label became very salient in people's minds. You might ask why some identities become more salient than others. For example, the majority of terrorist attacks are carried out by men. But while it's very common for Manipa to be questioned about why Muslims commit acts of terrorism, no one has ever asked me to explain why men become terrorists.
是以伊斯兰教的名义。因此，这种身份或那个标签在人们的心中变得非常显眼。你可能会问，为什么有些身份会比其他身份更显眼。例如，大多数恐怖袭击都是由男性实施的。但是，虽然穆尼巴经常被质问为什么穆斯林会实施恐怖主义行为，却从来没有人要求我解释为什么男性会成为恐怖分子。
Manipa says that has to do with who's in the majority and who's not. Think about it as a jar or red marbles. If you only have a single blue marble within that jar, then wherever that blue marble is moving, that's going to become very salient to you. Because in that jar of red marbles, that blue marble sticks out a little bit more. And so I think there's a little bit of that happening
穆尼巴说，这与谁占多数、谁不占多数有关。把它想象成一个装满红色弹珠的罐子。如果你在这个罐子里只有一个蓝色弹珠，那么无论那个蓝色弹珠移动到哪里，它对你来说都会变得非常显眼。因为在这个红色弹珠的罐子里，那个蓝色弹珠更加显眼一些。所以我想，这种现象在某种程度上也正在发生
in the way in which we oftentimes encounter new stories that are referring to racial and ethnic minorities. Of course, the 9-11 attackers explicitly said they were acting in the name of all Muslims. They didn't say they were acting in the name of all men. But Munibah's point is that because Muslims are a small minority and men are not, the misdeeds of Muslims become salient to us. This also holds true for other minorities and other crimes. The researcher Shanto Aiyangar at Stanford University once conducted a study where he presented stories about local crime to volunteers. He found that when volunteers saw that an African-American perpetrator was responsible for a crime, volunteers tended
在我们经常遇到涉及种族和族裔少数群体的全新故事的方式中。当然，9·11袭击者明确表示他们是在所有穆斯林的名义下行事的。他们并没有说他们是在所有男性的名义下行事的。但穆尼巴的观点是，正因为穆斯林是少数群体而男性不是，穆斯林的恶行对我们来说就变得显眼了。这也适用于其他少数群体和其他罪行。斯坦福大学的研究员香托·扬加尔（Shanto Iyengar）曾进行过一项研究，他向志愿者展示了关于地方犯罪的故事。他发现，当志愿者看到一名非裔美国肇事者对犯罪负责时，志愿者往往
to extrapolate the stigma of criminality to African-Americans as a group. When a white American was responsible for an identical crime, volunteers typically saw the criminal as being an individual, an aberration rather than the rule. Terrorist attacks also trigger another psychological phenomenon, whereas normally we might see that a group of a billion people has enormous diversity, all kinds of different attitudes and political views. Terrorism causes many Americans to view the entire Muslim world as fundamentally homogenous. The idea behind that phenomenon is actually referred to as outgroup homogeneity. And all that is saying is that when the behavior or when the action is involving an outgroup,
将犯罪的污名外推到作为群体的非裔美国人身上。而当一名白人美国人对相同的犯罪负责时，志愿者通常认为这个罪犯是一个个人，是一个反常现象而不是常态。恐怖袭击也会引发另一种心理现象：通常我们可能会看到一个拥有十亿人口的群体的多样性是巨大的，有着各种各样不同的态度和政治观点，而恐怖主义却导致许多美国人将整个穆斯林世界视为根本上同质化的。这一现象背后的概念实际上被称为“外群体同质性”（outgroup homogeneity）。而这所要表达的全部内容是，当行为或行动涉及外群体时——
the group that you don't belong to, then you think that all individuals within that group are in fact represented by that particular idea or that particular attribute. So you think that the entire out group is homogeneous and they're all the same, they all talk the same, they all behave the same. So if one of them did something, then others must believe and act in the same way as well. The way the media portrait terrorism has serious effects not just on our perceptions of Muslims, but on the public policies we support. In one study Munibah conducted, volunteers were randomly assigned to watch different clips of Muslims
也就是你不属于的群体——你就会认为该群体内的所有个体实际上都被那个特定的想法或特定的属性所代表。因此，你认为整个外群体是同质的，他们都是一样的，他们说同样的话，表现也一样。所以，如果他们中的一个人做了某事，那么其他人也一定以同样的方式去相信和行动。媒体对恐怖主义的描绘产生了严重的后果，不仅对我们对穆斯林的看法，而且对我们所支持的公共政策也产生了严重影响。在穆尼巴进行的一项研究中，志愿者被随机指派观看关于穆斯林的不同的剪辑视频
before answering a series of questions. Some volunteers watched news clips in which Muslims were represented as terrorists. Others saw neutral clips about Muslims. A third group saw positive news clips, clips that showed Muslims volunteering in their communities. And immediately after being exposed to the video clips, we asked them what they think about Muslims in terms of how aggressive they are, how violent they are. But we also asked them whether they support various kinds of public policies that are targeting Muslims. And some of these were policies that were more for international countries, so military action Muslim countries, and other policies were more domestic.
在回答一系列问题之前。一些志愿者观看了穆斯林被表现为恐怖分子的新闻剪辑。其他人观看了关于穆斯林的客观中立剪辑。第三组观看了积极的新闻剪辑，即展示穆斯林在其社区中做志愿者的剪辑。就在接触到视频剪辑后，我们询问了他们对穆斯林的看法，涉及他们有多激进、多暴力。但我们还询问了他们是否支持针对穆斯林的各种公共政策。其中一些政策更多地针对国际国家，比如对穆斯林国家的军事行动，而另一些政策则更多地针对国内。
So, harsher civil restrictions for Muslim Americans. And what we discovered is that participants who were in the negative news condition ended up thinking of Muslims as more aggressive as more violent and subsequently supported policies that were targeting Muslims both domestically and internationally compared to those who were in the neutral or positive news condition. So continuous coverage of Muslims as terrorists is simply activating and strengthening these kinds of associations, ultimately facilitating us to think of Muslims in an aggressive manner
因此，对美国穆斯林实施更严厉的公民限制。我们发现的是，处于负面新闻条件下的参与者最终认为穆斯林更加激进、更加暴力，并随后比处于中立或积极新闻条件下的参与者更支持在国内外针对穆斯林的政策。因此，将穆斯林持续报道为恐怖分子，仅仅是在激活和强化这些类型的联想，最终促使我们以激进的方式思考穆斯林
and then support harmful behavior towards them. What was striking about this paper was not just that people supported aggressive foreign policy interventions, but they actually supported more aggressive policies toward American citizens who happen to be Muslim. That was actually fascinating for me to know that a lot of Americans are not defensitating between Muslims who are living in other countries versus Muslim Americans who are citizens
然后支持针对他们的有害行为。这篇论文令人震惊的地方不仅在于人们支持激进的外国政策干预，还在于他们实际上支持对碰巧是穆斯林的美国公民采取更激进的政策。对我来说，这实际上是令人着迷的，因为很多美国人并没有区分生活在其他国家的穆斯林与身为公民的美国穆斯林
and who are perhaps their neighbors and their friends. So we saw people supporting policies such as domestic surveillance, without the consent of Muslim Americans, we saw individuals supporting perhaps that Muslim Americans should not be allowed to vote, that they should have separate and more thorough airport security lines, that they should be monitored, you know, by the government, their phones should be tapped without their consent. All kinds of unconstitutional policies, we saw American supporting those. So, when I look at this body of research, what I'm seeing when I step back and look at it, is a series of processes that in some ways are driven
他们或许是他们的邻居和朋友。因此，我们看到人们支持诸如在未经美国穆斯林同意的情况下进行国内监视的政策，我们看到个人支持或许不应该允许美国穆斯林投票，他们应该有单独且更彻底的机场安检队伍，他们应该受到政府的监控，他们的电话应该在未经同意的情况下被窃听。所有这些违宪的政策，我们都看到美国人在支持。因此，当我审视这一系列研究时，当我退后一步去看它时，我看到的是一系列在某种程度上受到驱动的过程
by fairly understandable and normal human mental processes. The idea that we see aboriginal things or unusual things happening together, we draw correlations between them, we see patterns, and members of the news media, of course, are human beings. So they gravitate towards certain stories and cover those stories more aggressively because those stories stick out in their minds, they're more salient. As a result of that kind of media coverage, your research is finding that the attitudes
是由相当可以理解和正常的关乎人类心理的过程所驱动的。我们看到反常的事情或不寻常的事情一起发生，我们在它们之间得出相关性，我们看到规律，而新闻媒体的工作人员当然也是人。因此，他们倾向于某些故事，并更积极地报道这些故事，因为这些故事在他们的脑海中更加突出，它们更加显眼。由于这种媒体报道，你的研究发现
of Americans themselves is changing in a way that becomes hostile to what people living in their communities who are fellow American citizens who happen to be Muslim. And what is so troubling is that these relatively innocuous psychological biases can eventually have consequences that are anything but innocuous. I think what's really important is to realize that these biases are not just simply something that's in our head,
美国人自身的态度正在发生变化，变得对生活在其社区中、碰巧是穆斯林的同胞美国人充满敌意。而真正令人不安的是，这些相对无害的心理偏见最终会产生任何东西都不算无害的后果。我认为真正重要的是要认识到，这些偏见不仅仅是存在于我们头脑中的东西，
but they are in fact affecting our behaviors and our public policy decisions towards Muslims, both in this country and outside. And also the other side of things, which I've actually just recently started looking at, is how the same media representations are influencing Muslim-American youth and adolescents who are growing up in this country who identify both as Muslim and as American. It's making them feel as if they cannot be both of those identities, even though there is no reason why they should feel that way. They're having to feel as if they have to choose one over the other, because they're being questioned
但它们实际上正在影响我们对穆斯林的的行为和公共政策决定，无论是在国内还是国外。还有另一个方面的内容，我也在最近才开始研究，那就是同样的媒体代表是如何影响那些在这个国家长大的、既认同自己是穆斯林又认同自己是美国人的美国穆斯林青年和青少年的。这让他们觉得他们无法兼顾这两种身份，尽管他们没有任何理由去产生这种感觉。他们不得不觉得他们必须在两者之间做出选择，因为他们受到了质疑
about their American identity on account of being Muslim. They're having to answer questions about their loyalty, their patriotism as an American, and that is in fact affecting how they think about themselves psychologically, their physical health, their self-esteem, and a host of other important consequences. In some ways, these findings are disheartening. It does feel like a vicious cycle. I asked Muni Bay if she saw any way to combat the psychological biases that terrorism produces.
关于他们的美国身份，仅仅因为他们是穆斯林。他们必须回答关于他们的忠诚、作为美国人的爱国主义的问题，而这实际上正在影响他们在心理上如何看待自己、他们的身体健康、他们的自尊心以及许多其他重要的后果。在某些方面，这些发现令人沮丧。这确实感觉像是一个恶性循环。我问穆尼巴，她是否看到有任何方法可以消除恐怖主义所产生的心理偏见。
I think one of the greatest ways to break this cycle, and this is supported by both anecdotal evidence, but also research is contact, increase contact with Muslims. Of course, especially when it's positive, tends to decrease reliance on these kinds of biases and then subsequently, you know, support for these kinds of harmful actions. So time and time after again, we see that those Americans who have more contact with Muslims and more frequent contact tend to report less
我认为打破这个循环的最伟大方法之一——这得到了轶事证据以及研究的支持——就是接触，增加与穆斯林的接触。当然，特别是当它是积极的时候，往往会减少对这类偏见的依赖，然后随之减少对这些有害行为的支持。因此，一次又一次地，我们看到那些与穆斯林接触更多、接触更频繁的美国人倾向于报告较少
of these kinds of biases, tend to not support these kinds of policies as much. They tend to look at the media reports in a more critical manner and they have a very good understanding that what they see in the media is not the entire story. So contact is definitely one of the most important things that we can talk about and we can encourage individuals to pursue in order to break this vicious cycle. Munibas Alim is a social psychologist at the University of Michigan. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Penman and Raina Cohen. Our staff includes Jenny Schmidt, Renee Clar and Parthas Shah.
这类偏见，往往不那么支持这些类型的政策。他们倾向于以更加批判的眼光看待媒体报道，并且他们非常清楚，他们在媒体上看到的不一定是全部的事实。因此，接触绝对是我们能够讨论并鼓励个人去追求的最重要的事情之一，以便打破这个恶性循环。穆尼巴·萨利姆是密歇根大学的社会心理学家。本期的Hidden Brain由玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）和莱娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）制作。我们的工作人员包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、蕾妮·克拉克（Renee Clar）和帕尔塔·沙阿（Parthas Shah）。
Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Our unsung heroes this week are the staff of NPR1. Viet Li, Emily Barakas and Jenny Gathwright-picked stories that help listeners find shows like Hidden Brain. You can download the NPR-1 app in the App Store that's NPR-ONE. You can follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen for my stories each week on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, please give us a rating on iTunes or wherever you listen to your podcasts. I'm Shankar Betanthum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的监督制片人是塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）。我们本周的无名英雄是NPR1的工作人员。越南语李（Viet Li）、艾米丽·巴拉卡斯（Emily Barakas）和珍妮·加思韦特（Jenny Gathwright）挑选了帮助听众找到像Hidden Brain这样节目的故事。您可以在App Store下载NPR-1应用程序，即NPR-ONE。您可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并且每周都可以在您当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果您喜欢本期节目，请在iTunes或您收听播客的任何地方给我们评分。我是尚卡尔·韦兰塔姆，这是NPR。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。